people need to understand that when
you're watching donald trump fight tooth
and nail
you know with a variety of lawsuits he
has the democrats aren't sitting around
doing nothing
no they they've they've got their their
version of fighting
and i suppose in some places like
pennsylvania it's ramming through
certification before anyone realizes
what's happening
because i didn't even realize i i when
when
when i found out i was like wait what
that was today what because i was i was
i was tracking certification of all
these states and i'm like michigan is
this day here's what we're waiting for
the state board of canvassers and then i
thought pennsylvania was going to be
way later then it just happened yeah and
then i'm watching you know in michigan
too and it's the same thing it's these
weird
the democrats strategy has been the
entire time
you know what i'm gonna be careful on my
in the words that i use but
since the beginning of the uh uh even
before 2016
i remember i was in san jose california
i think it was in 2015 maybe 20 i think
it was 2015 maybe 2016.
and i watched a guy walking out of a
trump rally just minding his own
business people were screaming at him he
looked all confused and someone runs up
behind him and smacked him in the back
of the head with some bag full of heavy
objects
and it caught him pretty bad and he was
bleeding and he was all like what's
happening
since that day and before but for me
since that day
i've been watching them basically say to
anybody who supports republicans or
trump
we will physically hurt you we will
physically hurt your family
we will destroy your life we will target
your job if you dare say anything now
it's crazy
trump's secret voters they said in the
press they didn't exist
oh no trump secret vote is not a real
thing nate silver and 5 30. there's no
secret trump voters no evidence
and then all their polls were wrong by
massive and historic march again this
time again
this time worse than last time yeah it
was like i i think
trafalgar 24 7 trafalgar got it
got it right to the extent that you can
um
but you know i i've been to two
no three rallies with with the president
and you know one in latrobe one in moon
township one in butler
i've never seen anything like it in my
life
they are positive they're like a they're
like a concert
environment with the most diverse group
of people that you can imagine
and they're all friendly they all love
america
they're fun people have a blast but then
and then you then you drive home
right and then you watch it portrayed on
the media and they treat
like they treat it like it's this
negative yeah that's the truth
and they just the president makes
jokes right on stage and when you're
there in the moment you can feel the
environment you know he's joking but
then take
this is why i said like leading into the
show you can't make jokes in politics
right you just can't like ever
you can't you can't have any fun you
can't make any jokes um but the
president jokes
and then they take the president out of
context and then they say he's saying
some inflammatory remark
and they make the rallies seem like
they're super negative um
and and they did this with me too like i
went on a show with uh
called on pc on fox news the show is
hosted by a stand-up comedian
the whole point of the show is to take
up unpolitically correct
uh uh positions and defend them and make
jokes and i i made jokes about the idea
of independent women and it
you know you know women need men and of
course one of the hosts of the show is a
woman who i'm friends with trying to
like get her going a little bit we were
having fun
but what they did was during my during
my campaign was clip that up and attack
me like
like somehow i hate women it's like wait
a second it's a comedy show that's not
true
that's part of the tactics we've seen
over the past several years the cancel
culture
they they exactly so so think about this
trump managed to gain like what is what
is what is he up like 11 or 12
million 11 million voters over 11
million new voters
more 11 million more people in 2020
voted for him but but here's the crazy
thing so secret trump voters existed
a lot of them and it was because of in
my opinion many reasons but the threats
of the left to take your job away from
you
that these people weren't going around
ex explaining to others why they should
vote for trump as well
so i know a bunch of celebrities who
have hit me up saying you know if
anybody ever found out as a trump
supporter my career would be over
and i've said uh um indirectly you're a
coward
because you're going to wake up one day
trump is going to lose and you're going
to say if
only i risked more and instead you are
willing to sacrifice what you think this
country needs for yourself
but this is not not to drag those who
are scared of the left
but the strategy of the democrats the
whole time has been
partly because i would say there's a lot
of activist groups but democratic
activists
know they've threatened people there
have been mobs
they have come for the board of
canvassers they came to my house they
went to your house
did you see did you see what they did in
my they spray painted oh that's right
yeah they came to my house
yeah you know um you know and
people are like oh parnell did that
himself i'm like you think with
i got between the two of us we got six
kids do you think i got time to go out
and spray paint my damn garage with red
paint like
ain't nobody got time for that auntie
but they they came to my house
you know and and and that's my thing
after having been i'm an infantry combat
veteran i've been
485 days of heavy combat in in the
in the hindu kush mountains of of heavy
combat you know
uh my platoon took an 85 percent
casualty right like
i took real life flak in afghanistan
like you know i was wounded over literal
flak
yeah like i can take this too and to me
and i've said this to you before but
i mean it when i say i don't take an
oath to a political party my
i love this country i love the people of
this country and my my oath is to the
constitution this isn't a popularity
contest and maybe i'm in the wrong
profession because
elections are kind of like a popularity
contest
definitely but you know it's crazy it's
crazy how politics
it's it you know war and and politics uh
go hand in hand it's a fight for control
for power
and you know in many instances and you
know you give me thought you give me
your thoughts on this but war happens
when the speaking stops when the when
the ability to sure
when the ability to control someone or
get what you want ends with with
negotiation
they find another way to do it yeah they
they say that that war is like
the what the last twenty the i don't
remember i don't know what the phrase is
like the la
is you know the last 25 yards of foreign
policy or something like foreign policy
fail
for failure or whatever but um yeah i
always say that politics is war just
without the bullets you know
uh it is and it is um you know but for
me
it's not about it's not about like
having been in charge of soldiers lives
right where every decision that you make
might mean if it's a bad decision that
somebody goes home in a body bag
i've had i've had real power at a young
age
and what i learned in having that power
as one learning to wield it responsibly
but not even wield it
leadership is about taking the power
that's bestowed upon you
and giving it back to the people that
you lead
right and empowering them uh to do what
they believe in their hearts is right
and so that that's how i see the job of
of politician right and i hate that word
in fact every time i say it i throw up
in my mouth a little bit but for me
this job like my ultimate goal like
having if if i ever win an election in
my life would be to go to washington
hit the reset button on everything and
then move back to western pennsylvania
and like buy a farm and never talk to
anybody
else again when the mission is complete
right because i am not uh
you know being a politician in
washington while it would be a
tremendous honor to represent the people
that's not like
the pinnacle of my life's ambition you
know the challenge is the war is never
ending you know in in in actual warfare
you can
take the ground and then you're like we
got it you secure it we're good or
whatever or you know the war can be
ended
but in terms of politics there's always
pushback so you get into congress
and you say hey we're going to stop
these things they're unconstitutional
they're pushing back the whole time
endlessly yeah and in the left and the
thing about the left is that they
they know how to fight they know how to
organize
you know newt gingrich says it says it
best republicans care about campaigns
democrats focus on elections
right interesting he's right about that
you know the campaign that we ran for
congress i would say was the best in the
country
we had thousands and i mean thousands of
volunteers but they were changing the
rules
they were changing the rules they
changed the rules and they said you know
it reminds me of that old quote
um put me in charge of a nation's money
and i care not who makes the laws
who said that is that is that a real
quote maybe it's just something on the
internet you just you just made
sure he just made up yeah i think it was
like nathan rothschild something
oh nathan rothschild interesting well i
i will tell you
you're you're right i i think you were
right to a certain extent they
they made sure the rules benefited them
um
you know you look at our experience on
election night right now let's walk
through what happened right on election
night
had you know we're spent we spent it
with friends and family at my house
uh we run up the score we were up on
lamb on election night by
17 points oh over 43
000 close to 45 000 votes like we're up
on 45 000 votes on election night
uh and then all of a sudden allegheny
county
stopped counting and we're like wait why
is allegheny county stopping
counting why are they doing that and
so they're supposed to start counting
again uh the day after election day at
10 in the morning right right
did they start counting at 10 in the
morning no yeah but a guy named
rich fitzgerald who is the ranking
member on the board of elections
went out and did a media blitz instead
and said we're confident
that when all the all when the election
is done
and the ballots are counted congressman
lamb is going to have a two percentage
point lead
huh and i'm sitting there with my team
thinking well that is you know what
that that takes some gumption you know
that's that's a
you're always predicting your boys down
by 45 000 votes precise predictions we
we
knew on election night and we had run
tabulations these are not projections
right because we knew
how many mail-in ballots there were for
lamb for me and independence and
yeah and we said if lamb got everything
he was supposed to get and i got
everything i was supposed to get and we
split independence even give him 60
of independence he had no mathematical
path we'd have a
margin of victory about of over just
over 13 000 votes
people were calling us to congratulate
us i mean a couple
i think a couple of news outlets called
the race for us because again there was
no
honest mathematical path but they found
them
so so so so after the rich fitzgerald's
media blitz
they start counting the vote the day
after election day at about 2
30. and and the race tightened
because lamb had more mail-in votes than
we did and we expected that right
and then at 8 30 or about 8
30. there were two male there were two
ballot dumps one of four thousand one of
nine thousand all for lamb
almost exclusively offer lamb you know
the percent 20
20 almost all for lamb like 25 minutes
later listen like 25 minutes later he
scampers out to the podium and declares
victory
now there are still 25 000 ballots left
to count
like not not mail-ins like provisionals
and things like that and in beaver
county in butler county
how are you going out and declaring
victory with a razor thin
margin of like a thousand votes at that
point unless you know something that i
don't
what did he what did he do before he ran
for congress he was a federal prosecutor
the guy's never known a job
outside the government he's never had to
earn a private paycheck in his life but
the point i'm trying to make is
what we're trying to get answers like
where did those ballots come from
you know yeah allegheny county so so you
you knew how many mailing vote
votes there were and that's not a
projection we knew
you know but then when they came in they
were all for lamb is that what happened
almost all almost all is that what
surprised you
yes yes right now lamb is up by like 8
000 or so votes so that was the
difference
interesting and so we still don't we
still don't know
where where those ballots came from but
they weren't part of the original totals
like i said not not that we are aware of
that's weird but like so and so on a
smaller
scale right so when you're talking like
the same thing that happened to me
on a smaller scale happened to to the
president
in places like milwaukee and detroit
right uh and philadelphia well you're
talking about beaver county these 2 000
ballots that could change your election
well i you know i i don't know if it
i don't know if it would be enough
to change the election but i will say in
a few hours time uh they found
2 000 ballots that were very
questionable now if we had more time
looking more nursing home facilities
8 000 votes in a race where
you know 434 440 000 people voted
are you gonna are you going to call for
a hard audit like
the pennsylvania state legislature
called for one and then they did it they
had a committee and they said
oh you know what we can't find a
contractor to do it in 60 to 90 days so
we can't do the audit
but can't you do something about that
we're trying to raise money
um in election defense fund money and
we're certainly doing that
with the lawsuit with acts 77 as we
talked about and we we need to look at
each and every ballot those those
mail-in balances that's exactly
that's exactly it you need to have a
democrat republican and an independent
all look at it
and verify it the challenge is but
listen man
i'll tell you this i honestly don't
think any of that matters you know why
it's a propaganda war
you could you could personally find a
ballot that has
never been folded that looks machine
printed and the democrats will call you
a liar
you could actually have a legitimate
argument this is unconstitutional and we
didn't know until now
and they'll say you're just trying to
cheat the election oh oh that's and
that's exactly it's just propaganda that
well that's certainly how many
certainly what they're doing with me
it's about how many people can they
convince
which side to be on yeah it's true it
it's true
and and the democrats are democrats are
good at that they're good at that
and that's so so to go back i did google
search i do believe that quote is not
real
you just made it up that's profound no
no no it's a very famous quote on the
internet but it's like attributed to
different people so
i found a bunch of different sources
saying it was nathan rothschild but it's
not
confirmed they also say it's attributed
to
mayor amschel roth's child or maybe
andrew fletcher
so twitter told me that it was mayor
rothschild and i believe everything i
read on twitter so i'm gonna
permit me to issue and control the money
of a nation and i care not who makes its
laws
i'll put it this way give me control of
the rules of an election and i don't
give a crap about
someone's campaign i don't care how they
campaign
if you can change the rules then what
does it matter well and
look that's certainly what that's
certainly what
the democrats did this election you know
it's funny republicans end up losing
because
they didn't cheat well i mean what
happens is
is what hap what happens is is that
you know out in california where ballot
harvesting and stuff is legal
is that two election cycles later
republicans catch up and fight the way
that they fight and then we start
winning again but then you're like then
then it's like but but but there's no
election but is it an election or are we
just playing a game but
it's not just that it's that you don't
have the media on your side to control
and manipulate narratives although
or or schooling or entertainment or any
cultural
cultural institutions that's another
thing uh one of the quotes i heard is
that republicans care about winning
elections and democrats care about
winning control of cultural institutions
because politics is downstream from
culture well that's that's the truth
that's the truth and that and that's why
i part of the reason why i do what i do
writing fiction and
stuff like that i mean like is because
conservatives are really bad at it
well yeah your stuff's probably good
though
well i i am a i feel like i am
an anomaly when it comes to mainstream
conservatism like i i'm
you know i play music i play the guitar
about in high school play guitar and
bass and
uh i like music like i can appreciate
art like there's a creative side too to
me that i think a lot of conservatives
don't have and i think
you know you know democrats are very
good at making emotionally resonant
political arguments right yeah you know
martin luther king was an amazing
cultural icon
i have a dream speech inspired 500
000 people to show up on the washington
mall without emails or cell phones right
but i have a dream was not i have a ten
point plan this is like a sign i'm
stealing a little bit from simon sinek
here but my point is is that
i feel like republicans need to get
better at making emotionally compelling
arguments and not trotting out a
10-point plan
yep and so the democrats end up with
people who win power by promising
you know whispering sweet nothings into
the ears of their constituents like
that's why there's a tendency it's why
the democrats are the party of
continually moving further and further
left andrew yang tweeted something to
the effect that he's literally offering
people money to vote for him
something like that the ubi plan if you
vote for me you get your money
universal basically yeah yeah even
though it's failed everywhere it's been
tried
um i like andrew yang um i was a bigger
fan earlier on i think he's really gone
way too establishment in recently but uh
he early on he lost me when that dude
spray paint
uh sprayed whipped cream in his mouth do
you remember that
yeah like it was just a little bit it's
right it's a little weird i'm like you
know i i thought
look i can appreciate it see that's an
emotional argument i can
i can appreciate not i can appreciate
non-conformist politicians people who
mar i love that in fact you know i uh
but that was that was literally trying
to do do you know about uh yeah yeah you
know about the moral foundations
jonathan heights research
conservatives there's uh initially they
said there were five moral foundations
now they say they're six
um basically liberals operate on only
two
care and fairness and so i think let me
see if i can about the top of my head
there's care fairness
purity authority what am i missing
i don't remember purity there's a
liberty and there's one more let me
look at my brother i'm missing one so
conservatives have
uh of to varying degrees equal balance
of all of the moral foundations
so uh you know um let's see authority
for instance it's very obvious like
trusting and respecting the authority to
a certain degree
yeah there's also liberty though so that
balances out authority like your right
and your freedom
but when it comes to making an argument
to convince a traditional liberal
it's just care and fairness that's why
they go after
these people are nazis that's why they
say they're racists because they're
targeting
it's not fair they don't care in reality
the democrats don't either they've just
found the weakness of certain people
that they can use to exploit
i only have the five i have care
fairness or care slash harm
uh i have fairness less cheating loyalty
slash betrayal authority and subversion
and then sanctity and degradation
yeah and then liberty was what they
added yeah okay yeah so so libertarians
operate this is really funny
libertarians have one moral foundation
liberty no joke
that's why they they i think that's why
they added it because they were like
when we're doing a test like
we don't care about any of that just let
me be free
just just do whatever you want to like
very strange degrees but like uh
sanctity is is one so this is like
respecting the family and uh you know
things like innocence and protecting
kids
maybe uh that's probably loyalty but
it's probably a combination
yeah and the left it's just care and
fairness
yeah so it's like you go to them and say
these poor children these poor children
and they'll be like i'll vote for you
they don't care about what the argument
is they don't care about what the result
is
literally just don't be mean but then
the weird thing about is it's really
easy to rile up many of these
traditional liberals
to be mean and unfair and and
unaccountable
it's interesting if you think about this
the attack on me
in my lawsuit to try to protect all of
pennsylvania voters from not being
disenfranchised
with the way that they try to paint me
is is emotional
fairness right like you want to
disqualify
2.5 it's weight it's like that's not
true in fact at all
that's that's projecting they changed
the rules both republicans and democrats
that's true
changed the rules and played fast and
loose with the will of the people
and now that's the best thing they can
do it's why they say this is what i love
trump's the fascist the fascist who's
signing peace agreements withdrawing our
troops from the middle east
and who did not invoke the insurrection
act to go crush
protesting and rioting you're exactly
right if you told me
after having spent as enough time in
afghanistan to legally vote in that
country i swear
you know yeah if you told me that
president trump
was gonna sign middle east peace deals
and come closer to middle east peace
than any other president in my lifetime
i mean i think i i wouldn't have
believed you
what what else me neither energy
independence and i would have never
believed our country would have been
energy independence i always thought we
were going to be holding the countries
that hated us we're energy independent
uh we've got middle east peace deals the
president has
weakened our enemies like china and
russia
his foreign policy has been remarkably
successful his domestic policy almost
every demographic has lived a better
life under this president
again he performed better with latinos
and african-americans the president as
part of his agenda has been
lifting up the african-american
community with opportunity zones and
funding historically black colleges
the this guy has done more uh
for this country and gets absolutely no
credit and this is this is the thing
that kills me
do you think he needs this you know what
you know what i mean the guy that got
the guy's a billion think about this tim
the guy's a billionaire
right in 2016 he defeated a clinton in a
bush
right i mean people were like donald
trump's a buffoon
he's not smart the guy
created an empire yeah defeated a
clinton bush
and in four years did things for this
country that i never thought possible
you still hear people in the media so
he's a fascist
and he's dumb well so that's that's
that's the craziest thing i've ever
heard
the first thing is they're like trump's
the fascist now that we've defeated him
bring on the forced mandatory lockdowns
yeah in in newark new jersey the the
mayor was saying they didn't want no
you couldn't leave your home did you see
the police you know who
i love and i'm a big supporter of but
did you see the police like
arresting that guy who violated curfew
they're like put get your hands in the
cuffs and he's like there's like 20 of
you
on me i can't even move he's like why
are you tackling me he's like you
violated curfew
it's like which i've no i didn't see
that one it's it's it's crazy it's crazy
wow and and why why why why
why are we locking down again i don't
know it's against science well
there's no scientific scientifically
dubious the mask study that came out six
thousand participants three three
thousand people yeah the one from
denmark denmark yeah
three thousand no masks three thousand
with masks and
the people that wore masks changed out
their masks
every single day and you know what the
media says in this country about the
study who
determines that their masks don't really
help in fact they can
put you at more of a risk the media in
this country is like well you know
what the study actually means is that we
need to
wear more masks how could you possibly
come to that conclusion that's not what
the study says
you know how to talk about it they had
great interviews you're not allowed to
talk about any of this stuff you're not
you're not so this but this is it's very
obviously what they do
i think you know look democrats have
one very simple and easy path to victory
low
information voters it's why they target
the youth vote
so look you know you don't i can be more
disrespectful towards
the democratic politicians you know
you're you're trying to be probably for
the people all the people regardless
well i think we're
i think we're i think in our campaign
we're breaking but we had a ton of youth
support
we had but there are smart young people
but
like most young people lack the
experience to understand why we
you know i hear these it's really funny
when you when you see all these young
people
who are for socialist policies and i
mean literal socialist policies not
social democratic or like uh uh i'm
talking about these
social uh democratic socialists who want
to give the means of production
to the working class when these people
are not the working class that's
that's the funniest thing you look at
these dsa meetings the democratic
socialists of america and you see a
bunch of like 20
20 somethings who don't actually do the
hard labor jobs they're like the
managerial elites
they're the you know upper middle class
suburbanites claiming that they should
give
the control of you know the means of
production to the people
that's insane but then you see when they
actually do say stuff like health care
is a human right
like how how is it possible that someone
else's labor is your right
someone has to do that work now i
certainly think we can do our best to
make sure
that we grant healthcare to more people
because i'm actually a fan of
uh like base level universal healthcare
which would be if you break your arm if
you get the flu or something you can go
in and you don't have to worry about it
so that way we make sure that people
aren't dying in the streets so that
people aren't getting serious deformity
you know serious like
you know long-term permanent damage i
totally agree there needs to be a safety
net for everybody
but but the issue is when it comes to
rare and exotic
diseases or genetic elements that are
hard to cure we can't guarantee it as a
right
but here's what the democrats do they
they use these things that just
it's it's a a child's solution to a
grand
a grand problem the the easiest way to
explain it
is when you see these people say we have
more
empty homes than we have homeless people
problem solved so you can't just put a
homeless person in a random house
the house has to be maintained like
otherwise it falls apart you can get
hurt there's
building codes that be upheld you can't
just take a mentally ill person not all
homeless people but some
and this is what they don't understand
because a lot of young people don't have
the experience or the understanding and
i mean that with no disrespect they just
they have like you know
i spent my early 20s working at homeless
shelters and then i actually learned
wow homelessness has nothing to do with
laziness or for the most part
unemployment
typically it's an issue of mental health
and it's really hard to solve that
problem
i learned that then you hear these
people say just put them in a house i'm
like
i've worked with these people man we
need to be there for them you can't just
ignore this the democrats propose these
kinds of policies
that regular people don't understand why
it doesn't make sense well and i think
what you're speaking to is something
you're talking about cultural
institutions i
i don't i i think by and large
many schools are failing our our young
people oh yeah
you know we we don't teach civics
anymore
we don't teach real social studies
anymore finance
we don't teach finance yeah real
economics we don't
capitalism in this day and age is almost
a dirty word seriously
um you know schools should be like okay
for today's class how to form how to
file for an s corp
the difference between a c corp and s
corp an llc a 501c3 501c4
here's how you start your own business
yeah we don't do any of that well and
you talked about healthcare i mean i
you talked about having a base level of
care for everybody which i think is
important but i would like to see
you know we do association healthcare
plans for businesses to allow small
businesses to band together to have the
same purchasing power as large
corporations i think that's a good thing
but if it's me like let's take it a step
further right
and let's say let's let individuals band
together
of a certain age maybe with certain
healthcare needs have it all be
app-based technology and so individuals
band together for certain plans take it
a step further that way
healthcare becomes affordable for for
everybody and people can have
you know there's more competition
there's more flexibility this is the
interesting art thing about health care
too is uh
you know i think trump trump did this
right where they have to show the prices
for which take that will take place
january
something of 2021 but yes
that's huge that's a big deal it's a
it's a big deal and there's also i think
basically like you're getting your your
cost so you know i should go here it's
cheaper
there's a bill on the house floor i
think it's hr 19
but it's uh right now like prescription
drug prices in this country i don't know
how we got in this topic but they're
they're way too high
just talking about the left offering up
simple solutions well so with the left
i mean one of the things that the left
did was sign a prescription drugs
government price control
bill basically basically said mandated
pricing right
right like we know that that doesn't
work but there's a bill in the house
uh right now hr 19 that would that would
lower the cost of prescription drugs and
in a really pragmatic way
now how do we do that well right now did
you know that big pharma
companies pay small pharma companies to
not produce
produce generic drugs oh wow i didn't
know that yeah so what
h.r 18 which is they got a lot of
bipartisan support would eliminate that
would make that illegal they're there by
flooding the market
uh with generic drugs and driving the
cost of of generic drugs down and
generics are cheap that's
that's the thing too i think you know uh
with trump what's really interesting a
lot of the things we started seeing
implemented by businesses such as a
four-day work week two-week vacation
increased wages those happened naturally
due to a great economy free market
yeah and quite literally trump
deregulating
and exactly boosting the economy in a
variety of ways
uh i think one of the big issues um
trump's
position on immigration resulted in
uh not to get too into complicated
situations but
when we saw for instance in these
different chicken processing plants
illegal workers being you know deported
or whatever
then americans stepped up and said now i
finally can get a job
and so there were things like that that
was that very directly tied into
you know things trump was pushing
tariffs for instance opposing these free
trade agreements
which brought a lot of manufacturing
back to the united states
and for a variety of reasons the economy
started doing really really well the
left wanted wanted these things like a
four-day work week like vacation
through mandate by the government just
decreeing itself we're gonna pass a law
you have to do it
but it doesn't work that way it's it's
it's it's just like
giving someone uh it's it's almost like
you look maybe some of these politicians
just genu genuinely don't
know how any of the stuff works and
thinks they can just rubber stamp
everybody gets a house we're done well
that doesn't that that does not surprise
me
because many of these politicians have
never done
anything else but hold political office
right right
yeah bernie sanders yeah that's his
thing and joe biden been in
been in politics for 47 years he's been
on the wrong side of
literally every major decision that he's
ever had to make
literally oppose the obama someone the
the osama bin laden raid someone said he
lost to dukakis in 87
is that true i don't know that's funny i
i i don't know but
diddy he did like people were like over
there not again
yeah i mean even robert gates who's uh
barack obama's secretary of defense said
that he was on the he's been on the
wrong side of every major foreign policy
decision for his whole career now what
where is the where's the media on this
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast
irl podcast we do the show live monday
through friday at 8pm so come back to
check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms
for free if you want to listen to us
there thanks for hanging out
and we will see you all next time
you